>> Guy Lamolinara:
Good morning everyone.
Thanks for coming to the
National Book Festival today.
I'm Guy Lamolinara and I work
for the Library of Congress.
All day here, at the Library of
Congress National Book Festival;
we are recognizing and
celebrating the importance
of reading, and authors
and books.
The library makes it seem
easy to do every year,
but the truth is the National
Book Festival is a huge
undertaking, a huge financial
undertaking, but yet is free
for everyone because
of the generous support
from our sponsors
and supporters.
So, please spread the joy of
reading with your gift online
if you can at loc.gov/donate
and you can do
that from the festival app or
when you purchase books today.
Now onto the event that
you all are here for.
Before I begin, I want to
thank Pizza Hut BOOK IT!
Program for sponsoring
Kate DiCamillo
and Harry Bliss's presentation
today, and I also need
to tell you we are recording
this for later broadcasting
and if you have not already,
could you please
silence your cellphones.
Thank you.
Kate DiCamillo is the
beloved author of many books
for children including
"Flora Ulysses",
"The Tale of Despereaux",
both of which received
Newbery Medals.
Her most recent middle
grade novel,
"Raymie Nightingale" was an
instant number one New York
Times Best Seller and a
National Book Award finalist.
She is also the author
of "Because
of Winn Dixie" a
Newbery Honor book,
"The Tiger Rising" a
National Book Award finalist,
"The Miraculous Journey
of Edward Tulane" a number
one New York Times Best Seller
and "Mercy Watson" the series
which is illustrated
by Chris Van Dusen.
Kate is also a former
National Ambassador
for Young People's Literature
for the Library of Congress
and she has more than
twenty-two million books
in print nationwide.
Kate lives in Minneapolis
where she faithfully writes two
pages a day five days a week.
I've personally been lucky to
know Kate for several years
and I can tell you as you
would suspect that she is one
of the nicest people
you could ever meet.
I can also tell you Kate
has the world's best laugh.
So what you want to
do is make Kate laugh
and you will not
be disappointed.
The work of Harry Bliss is
very familiar to anybody
who reads the New
Yorker magazine.
He is both a cartoonist and
cover artist for the magazine
and he had drawn more than
fifteen New Yorker covers.
Harry has illustrated many
picture books including the
number one New York
Times bestselling series
by Doreen Cronin that began
with "Diary of a Worm"
and is he is both written
and illustrated several picture
books including "Grace for Gus"
and "Luke on the Loose."
I can tell you that Harry
loves meeting his fans.
He visits many schools across
the country and he interacts
with thousands of children all
over the world teaching
comics, drawing and satire.
He and Kate have collaborated
on their book "Good Rosie!"
Please welcome Kate
DiCamillo and Harry Bliss.
[ Applause ]
>> Kate DiCamilllo: So,
how are you all doing?
We don't have very long together
and Harry and I were trying
to figure out how to do this to
maximize it and we both agreed
that what we would like to do
is to talk with you all as much
as possible and Harry also
volunteered that he could have,
do I get this right, a
volunteer come up and do a.
>> Harry Bliss: Scribble.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: A scribble
and then he would
turn it into a.
>> Harry Bliss: Masterpiece.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Yeah, a
masterpiece, a masterpiece.
So, this; so, the first
question is does that sound good
to have Harry do that?
[Applause] Yes.
And then the second question
is, do you all have questions
and we can just kind
of interact?
We'll show you, well
let's just do a,
we'll show you a
little bit about what
"Good Rosie" is about, and
typically when an author
and illustrator do books
together you don't do
them together.
Usually the publisher
decides who's going
to illustrate a book, but Harry
and I had done a book together
before and we had also,
Harry had illustrated a
poem that I had written
that had a dog in
it and we had wanted
for a longtime to do a dog book.
So, we collab; we decided that
we were going to do this book
and it is; how many
of you all have dogs?
That's excellent.
How many have cats?
Okay. So, Harry and
I are dog people.
So, this is just the story of
a dog who meets some other dogs
at a dog park and not a lot
happens, but a lot happens.
So, Harry do you want to take
it from there for a minute?
>> Harry Bliss: Yeah,
with the book?
>> Kate DiCamilllo:
Yeah with the book.
>> Harry Bliss: Yeah.
I love dogs.
I love all animals, but in
particular, I'm fifty-four
and something happened.
>> Kate DiCamilllo:
I'm fifty-four too.
>> Harry Bliss: Yeah.
>> Kate DiCamilllo:
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> Harry Bliss: You Pisces?
>> Kate DiCamilllo:
I'm an Aries.
>> Harry Bliss: Oh, okay.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Yeah, yeah.
>> Harry Bliss: So, yeah
this is serendipitous
that this book came about.
So, this is George and
Rosie lives with George.
Rosie is a good dog.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Yeah.
>> Harry Bliss: You're
supposed to read this, right?
>> Kate DiCamilllo:
Oh, should I read it?
>> Harry Bliss: Yeah, well
let's go to the next one.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Oh.
Oh, Harry isn't that
beautiful art I have to say?
I mean, it's just like don't
you want to pick her up?"
[ Applause ]
>> Harry Bliss: Thank you.
Well, I chose, I chose to do
this in comic sequential panels
because I'm a cartoonist and I
love panels and I love the fact
that you can, the time, the
space between the panels it's
like a little beat in music
like a rest if you will, so.
So, there's Rosie and
she lives with George
and Rosie's a lonely dog.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Right.
>> Harry Bliss: Yeah.
>> Kate DiCamilllo:
She's lonely.
>> Harry Bliss: Yeah.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: She
feels a certain melancholy
which is a word that shows up
in a lot of my stuff actually.
But let's not think about that.
>> Harry Bliss: Let's
not talk about that.
>> Kate DiCamilllo:
Yeah, okay alright.
>> Harry Bliss: But
it's a good work though.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Yeah, yeah.
>> Harry Bliss: It is.
Rosie and George walk together
and sometimes Rosie
chases squirrels.
She runs very fast,
as fast as she can,
but she never catches anything.
You want to do George?
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Rosie
always returns to George.
I've been a good
dog Rosie, good dog.
But I can't see that part
over there where George.
>> Harry Bliss: Yeah.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Talks
about the clouds, yeah.
What does it say?
>> Harry Bliss: Well, he's "Look
at the clouds Rosie
aren't they magnificent?"
"That one looks like
Abraham Lincoln."
George thinks that the clouds,
that most clouds
look like presidents.
Rosie thinks that most
clouds look like squirrels.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: One day
George sees something different
in the clouds.
Say it.
>> Harry Bliss: "Look Rosie!
That one looks like a dog!"
>> Kate DiCamilllo: "The
cloud does look like a dog."
Rosie wags her tail,
"Hello, hello!"
she shouts.
>> Harry Bliss: "Woof-woof."
>> Kate DiCamilllo: The dog
cloud does not answer her.
Rosie feels lonely in an
empty bowel sort of way.
George looks down at Rosie.
He looks up at the cloud.
"Hmm."
>> Harry Bliss: Hmm.
"I've got an idea Rosie.
Let's try something new."
>> Kate DiCamilllo: And
something new is going
to be the dog park which is
where all the action begins.
Can you flip forward so we
can see some of who she meets?
This is Maurice.
>> Harry Bliss: Yeah,
she meets Maurice.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: [Brief
laughter] It doesn't go well
at first and then can you
flip until we see Fifi?"
>> Harry Bliss: Fifi
comes along.
There's Fifi.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Yeah.
>> Harry Bliss: "Yip-yip."
>> Kate DiCamilllo:
Yeah, there's Fifi, yeah.
And with both of these dogs
it doesn't go well at first,
but they [brief laughter], they
figure out how to be friends.
>> Harry Bliss: After
some real drama.
>> Kate DiCamilllo:
Yeah, after some drama.
So.
>> Harry Bliss: You know.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: That's one
of my favorite panels,
"Drop it!"
>> Harry Bliss: Yeah.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: "Drop it!"
Yeah.
>> Harry Bliss: Dogs being dogs.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: And that's
Fifi's tail hanging out there.
Yeah. But we won't, we won't
tell you all what happens,
but there is a little bit drama
and everything turns out okay.
But let's, let's see if you
guys want to ask questions
and then let's have
Harry do the art.
>> Harry Bliss: Yeah, yeah.
>> Kate DiCamilllo:
Do you think?
Because we can't.
Yes.
[ Inaudible Question ]
My favorite book that
I ever wrote myself?
Are you here with
a parental unit?
Where is that parental unit?
Oh, somewhere over there, okay.
And do you have brothers
and sisters?
So, where is the
mother of this child?
Because I've got a
question for you which is,
which of the children
do you love the best?
And I know, I know what
your mom would say.
"I love them equally,
but differently"
and that's the same way I feel
about any books that
I've written.
I see them as like deeply
flawed but loveable anyway
which is I'm not saying you're
deeply flawed, you seem lovely,
but do you know what I mean?
There are just, I feel intense
love for them that's equal
but I see them as individuals.
Yes.
[ Inaudible Question ]
What inspired me to write
"Because Winn-Dixie" is
a good question for now
because I had moved from
Florida to Minneapolis
and it was the first time in my
life I had been without a dog
and we know how many of you all
have dogs and also that some
of you have cats, but I just
could not, I could not get
over the fact that
I didn't have a dog.
I couldn't have one in the
apartment where I lived,
and also it was a brutal
winter in Minnesota
and I was homesick for Florida.
So, Winn-Dixie takes
place in Florida
and Winn-Dixie is
centered around a dog.
I could not have a dog, but
this is the beauty of writing
and of creating things.
I could make-up the best
dog that I could imagine
which was Winn-Dixie
the biggest, smelliest,
smilingest dog in the
world, so that's--
that's where that came from.
Yes, yes I see you.
>> Hi Kate, it's
lovely to see you.
Winn-Dixie was far and
away our daughters,
three daughters favorite
book of all-time,
so we do have a favorite.
I'm asking you, did you
have a Jack Russell in mind
when you wrote the story?
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Did I
have a Jack Russell in mind
when I wrote this story?
Did I Harry?
>> Harry Bliss: No, I
don't think you did.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: No.
I didn't. This is, but
this is the wonderful thing
about working with somebody
else's; what happened was Harry
and I saw each other at a
conference in North Dakota
and we're like when are we
going to do that dog book?
And it was a really
instructive moment for me,
because Harry said on the plane
back, he started doing sketches.
We didn't know what
we were going to do,
but he just started
making sketches of dogs
and he sent them to me and I
just kind of got a feel and none
of those were Jack Russells,
but that's where we started
and I started with just the feel
of those dogs and then tried
to feel my way into the story.
So, why did you select
a Jack Russell?
>> Harry Bliss: Jack Russell,
it's just they are
feisty little dogs
and they're beautiful,
all the color.
A buddy of mine had a Jack
Russell when I was growing up.
I just, they're just
adorable dogs.
I just, there's something
about a Jack Russell that.
>> Kate DiCamilllo:
There's some.
>> Harry Bliss: I think to the
fact that Rosie is a female.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Right.
>> Harry Bliss: I
don't know why,
but Jack Russell's always look
like females even
though they can be male.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Wow.
Alright, let's hope
the Jack Russells
of the world aren't listening,
you really hurt, okay.
So, yes.
>> My daughter would like
to know if you're going
to write a book about a cat
or if you would consider
writing a book about a cat?
>> Kate DiCamilllo: So,
am I going to write
a book about a cat?
Well, I did have a cat show
up in "Raymie Nightingale."
What about you Harry?
You got a cat book in you?
>> Harry Bliss: I don't know.
I'm going to retire soon, so.
I do love cats though
I have to say.
>> Did you read comic
books when you were a kid,
because of "Flora
and Ulysses" you,
there's a lot of comic books.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Yeah,
so did I read comic
books when I was a kid?
>> Yeah.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Yes.
And what I lived for, and Harry
and I have talked about this,
and I know that you've read
way more comics than I did,
but for me it was Peanuts.
I would go to the library
and there were these
huge Peanuts' treasuries
that while we, my brother and
I like wore those to shreds
and we were the only
people in the library
that checked them out, but we
just read those and read those
and read those and it really
informed not only "Flora
and Ulysses", but my love of
Peanuts shows up in this book
and Harry's love of Peanuts
shows up in this book, so.
>> Harry Bliss: Yeah, it's true.
There was a certain kind,
well melancholy is Peanuts
that I love and I still
love it to this day and I,
those same treasuries.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Yeah.
>> Harry Bliss: I had to
buy them again, you know,
because I beat them up
so much, but yeah Peanuts
and I love the fact that those
kids all populated that space
by themselves without
any adults.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Right.
>> Harry Bliss: They
also suffered.
You know, they dealt
with, you know,
some Charlie Brown was a
little depressed and a.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Right.
>> Harry Bliss: You know.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: And, and.
>> Harry Bliss: They had issues.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: And
they asked big questions.
>> Harry Bliss: They
asked big questions.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Yeah.
>> Harry Bliss: Yes.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: And
I love big questions.
Yeah.
>> What is your first
book that you ever wrote?
>> Kate DiCamilllo: What's my
first book that I ever wrote?
I have to know what your shirt
says, "Mermaids have more fun."
Oh, I would have said "Mermaids
have a great tale" you know,
t-a-l-e, but I'm not in charge
of your T-shirt but
I like it anyway.
Okay, so my first book was
"Because of Winn-Dixie"
and Harry what was your first?
>> Harry Bliss: A, my first
book was actually "Little Lit."
It was a compilation
of other parts
from telling old folk tales,
so I was in that book.
>> Kate DiCamilllo:
What year was that?
>> Harry Bliss: Wow,
1999 I think.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Okay.
Alright.
>> Harry Bliss: Yeah.
>> Kate DiCamilllo:
Um, yes sorry.
>> I'd like to ask a little
about your beginning
years; were they structured?
Did you have a lot
of empty time?
Were you a dreamer?
Did you go to preschool?
>> Kate DiCamilllo: You
really do want to know
about the early years, yeah.
>> Can you tell us of what
might have encouraged this great
imaginative ability of yours?
>> Kate DiCamilllo: You
kind of make me teary.
So, who was I as like a kid?
Alright, I was a kid that
grew up in a small town
in central Florida and,
and on a dead end street
with a neighborhood that was
all young kids on one side
and then three widow
ladies on the other side.
And so, the kids had
the run of the street
and also those three widow
ladies were all gardeners
and also were really glad
that all the kids were there
and we were welcome to
come into their houses
and onto their porches
and talk with them and all
of that shaped me considerably.
Did I go to preschool?
I did go to preschool.
I loved it.
I loved school in general.
Did you like school?
>> Harry Bliss: No.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Yeah, see.
Any real artist never likes
school I guess, but I loved it.
It was just like I loved it.
I loved reading and I was
lucky enough to have a mother
who facilitated my love
of reading and made sure
that I always had books,
bought them for me,
took me to the library
and read to me.
Can, and speaking of reading,
can I ask how many
teachers are out there?
How many of you teachers read
out loud to your classes?
Can we have a round
of applause for that?
[ Applause ]
If you're not getting it at
home, it can save your life
to get it someplace else.
So, for all of you
you're saving lives.
So, Harry do you want to talk
about what you were
like as a kid?
>> Harry Bliss: I was a.
>> Kate DiCamilllo:
You hated school.
>> Harry Bliss: I, well I
didn't, hate is a strong word.
I didn't hate school.
I didn't really fit
in in school.
So, and the library; the
library saved my life honestly.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Yeah.
>> Harry Bliss: Art and
libraries saved my life.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: How about
the librarians out there?
[ Applause ]
>> Harry Bliss: Yeah.
I will just say,
that's totally true.
So, I want to always make
the point of saying how much,
not to [inaudible],
but I love libraries.
They, we should give money
to libraries all the time.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Yeah.
>> Harry Bliss: Always give
money to libraries [applause].
I would have gotten into a lot
of trouble had it not
been for libraries.
My mom took me as a
little boy to, you know,
and I get lost in a library.
I was never worried
about losing my mom.
I felt very safe in
libraries, anyway.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Yeah.
>> Harry Bliss: We're
running out of time.
I know.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Oh, we are.
We're running out of; okay do
you want to do your drawing?
>> Harry Bliss: A quick drawing.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Okay, so
who's going to volunteer Harry?
I'm getting out of your way.
Somebody is going to come
up and do a squiggle.
>> I know.
>> Harry Bliss: Let's do.
It's hard I want to pick this
somebody over here maybe.
How about this little girl
right here in the pink?
Yeah. Can you get up here?
Here, here you have to, okay.
So, what's your name?
>> Kevin.
>> Harry Bliss: What's
your name?
>> Kevin.
>> Harry Bliss: Your
name's Kevin?
Kevin that's a great name.
That's.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Wow.
>> Harry Bliss: Kevin,
alright Kevin.
Here you go.
This magic marker is for
you and what you're going
to do Kevin is you're going
take this, you're going
to draw just a scribble
really fast right there.
Excellent gob.
Let's give Kevin a round
of applause [applause].
Here, let me; do you
want to sit down?
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Yeah.
>> Harry Bliss: You
can sit here.
>> Kate DiCamilllo:
Be a panelist.
>> Harry Bliss: That's
pretty cool.
So, my job is, well what I do
in schools all over the place is
to turn these scribbles
into something.
This is brain game.
I didn't make it up.
It's been around for many years.
Bill Peet, great children's
book writer and illustrator
if you're, you know Bill Peet.
So, I look at this
and I kind of see
if I can turn it into something.
Can you guys see that?
So, you guys are looking at it.
Are you imagining
what this could be?
>> Yes.
>> Harry Bliss: Okay,
so someone said no.
But don't join the
crowd, you know.
So, when that's happening
in your brain there are actually
various lobes of your brain
that are being fired
up right now,
so and there's proof
on this on fMRI's.
So, you can turn it sideways,
but Kate do you have any idea,
you know, you're
looking at this?
>> Kate DiCamilllo: I'm
looking at it on the screen.
I do have some ideas.
>> Harry Bliss: You do?
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Yeah, but
I'm not going to tell them.
>> Harry Bliss: Come on.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Yeah.
>> Harry Bliss: Share
them with me.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: I think
you get a cow out of that real,
I think yeah [brief laughter].
>> Harry Bliss: You know.
>> Kate DiCamilllo:
What's your idea?
>> Harry Bliss: Well,
you know, I don't know.
I grew up like it's a.
>> Kate DiCamilllo:
It's an amoeba.
No? Oh.
>> Harry Bliss: And okay.
Could be some sort of a dog.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Oh.
[ Background Conversations ]
>> Harry Bliss: It's an idea
for your next book
maybe, I don't know.
So a tail, foot here.
[ Background Conversations ]
Can you all see that there?
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Oh.
>> Harry Bliss: It's kind
of a dragon guy, right?
That's all I got.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: That's
pretty fabulous, yeah.
[ Applause ]
We should, you should,
you should sign it too.
Wait, yeah.
Or does she get to keep it?
>> Harry Bliss: She
gets to keep this.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Oh.
>> Harry Bliss: Kate
you want to sign this?
You should sign it.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: No.
I'm not signing it, but
you should sign that, yeah.
>> Harry Bliss: You
want to sign it?
We do it together.
Put your little autograph right
there and you can sell this
on eBay probably get
yourself fifty bucks.
This is so interesting the
way children approach this.
I find it fascinating.
You're the best.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Excellent.
Yah!
>> Harry Bliss: Here take this.
You take this with you.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Don't
fall off stage Harry.
>> Harry Bliss: Here,
you're going
to let me wait, okay
here come here.
Is this okay?
Jump. There you go.
Oh, that's not good.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Oh, uh-oh.
Are you alright?
Yeah, yeah.
Fifty-four I get it, so yeah.
>> Harry Bliss: Yeah,
you know what I mean?
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Are
we, where are we timewise?
>> Harry Bliss: How
much time do we have?
We have a couple minutes.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Two minutes.
Let's do, you want to
do another question?
Yes. Yeah.
Yeah.
[ Background Conversations ]
I'm going to, great; I'm going
to paraphrase what she said.
So, she read Winn-Dixie in class
and when she first started
reading she didn't know what the
word "melancholy" meant,
and then she learned it
from the book and you learned it
because of Littmus
Lonzenges right?
Because they produce a
feeling of melancholy in you,
and then also a friend
of hers went to Florida
and saw a Winn-Dixie store
and I remember the first
time I did a signing
where somebody came through the
line and showed me a picture
of a Winn-Dixie grocery
store and they're like "Look!
They exist."
And it's like, "Yes, I know."
I mean like a grew up a couple
blocks away from one in Florida.
So, but can we just
say about words,
and that how much you absorb
words through a story, and so,
people are always worried
about reading level
and you can learn
any word, right?
You're learning a ton of words
you might as well learn the word
"melancholy" and you
learned it right?
So, well-done.
Okay, one more question
and we're going to,
it's going be an
adult back there;
an adult child a
combination, okay yes.
>> Exactly.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Yes.
>> So, I was interested in the
inspiration for Edward Tulane
which is my favorite
book of yours
and my son has a
related question.
>> Why did you make
Edward Tulane a rabbit?
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Okay,
I can answer that question.
So, how many of you all
have read Edward Tulane?
Okay, so where did
the story come from?
It came from receiving
a rabbit doll as a gift
and when the friend handed
me this rabbit doll I said,
"What's his name?"
And she said, "Edward."
And I said, "Thank you very
much" and I took him home
and I put on the couch in
my living room and he's big.
He's like he comes up to here.
He's dressed in this
very elegant outfit
and every time I walked
into the living room,
I screamed because he's a
really creepy looking rabbit
and he's just sitting
there like this.
So, like the third night that he
was in the house I had a dream
about him where he
was under water face
down on the ocean floor
with no clothing on.
It's your basic naked
rabbit dream.
And I think that most writers
have naked rabbit dreams
and probably artists.
>> Harry Bliss: Many.
>> Kate DiCamilllo: Yes, right.
Yeah. And I just am the fool
who will standup here
and talk about it.
So, I thought that seems like
the beginning of a story,
so that's where Edward
came from.
And can I, let's do
one thing in closing,
for all of you books
matter so much.
Seeing other people in
stories and seeing yourself
in stories matters
so much right now.
So, thank you for being
here for books and thank you
for believing in the
power of stories.
[ Applause ]
We're going to sign
somewhere, so thank you,
thank you for being here.